- Come on, Todd.
Pick up, pick up, pick
up, pick up, pick up.
- Hey, I was wondering if
I'd hear from you Todd-ay.
Yes-Todd-ay, I thought,
"Maybe I'll hear from her Todd-morrow."
- Is Untitled Princess
Carolyn Project okay?
- She sure is!
- Oh, thank God.
- [Todd] Wait, you're talking about
Untitled Princess Carolyn
Project the baby, right?
- Who else would I be talking about?
- Well...
(upbeat music)
- Mr. Knickerbocker will see you now.
- Great!
(phone rings)
Oh, hold on one second.
Hello?
- Todd, I have to go to a photo shoot.
I need you to take the
baby for an hour or so.
- Well, you know how
much I love hanging out
with Untitled Princess Carolyn Project,
but I can't Todd-ay, because
of all these meetings I have,
but if my schedule
weren't so busy, I'd say,
"Sure, I'd be happy to."
- Great, I'll see you at
Vim in fifteen minutes.
- Um, okay?
I'll be right back.
Sorry about that.
(phones ring)
Hello?
- Todd, change of plans,
bring the baby over to me
at Smash Fox Studios.
- Okay, he had to cancel another meeting,
but he will see you now.
- I'll be right back.
- I'm going to level with you, Todd,
you making me wait made me angry,
and that made me respect you.
- Sorry, things have
just been a little hectic
since I've been helping out
with Untitled Princess Carolyn Project.
- Untitled Princess Carolyn Project?
I'm intrigued.
You think the project has legs?
- Yeah, she has legs.
- I'm thrilled to meet you.
The whole town is buzzing about
Untitled Princess Carolyn Project.
- Weird, but okay.
- We need something big.
Is Untitled Princess Carolyn Project
the kind of thing that makes lot of noise?
- She sure does!
- I'm in, name your price.
- Um...
Jonathan?
- We took a big swing with
Dick Wolf's Milwaukee shows.
Turns out audiences are not interested
in a whole night of Milwaukee,
so now we've got some slots to fill.
Do you think Untitled
Princess Carolyn Project
could live for several seasons?
- I don't see how those
things are related,
but I certainly hope so.
- Well, how can I help?
- You wanna help?
- Let's start with a two season pick-up.
- Yeah, sure!
Pick-up, drop-off, whatever
works best for you.
That would be great.
- Great!
- Well, here she is.
What time do you want me to pick her up?
- Wait, it's a baby?
- And she has legs.
- I already canceled
Milwaukee Waste Management.
I told the shareholders this
was gonna save the network.
We designed the poster!
Todd, we need a show.
We can't air a baby!
- So, long story short,
Pinky canceled the baby,
but now we owe him a TV show.
- Huh.